warlow he was telling sean spears this
is a long time coming and he's won power
obama way left here before getting his
hands on mjf this sunday on paper
they called that one of the best opening
matches in the history of aew's dynamite
and this sunday is their double or
nothing pay-per-view at the t-mobile
arena and one of the biggest matches of
the night is warlow against mjf and the
man is here welcome warlow it's good to
see you buddy
very nice to see you it's great to have
you on the show man appreciate it what
are you going to do to mjf on sunday
night
i am going to powerbomb mjf
until my arms go numb so we're talking
five six seven powerbombs
well he
made me go through ten belt lashes
that's right so i feel like he is owed a
minimal of ten power bombs oh that's
gonna be good now for those that are new
to the sport we have a picture of mjf so
we can see what the guy looks like he
was voted i think he was devoted the
most evil wrestler of 2021 he's a bad
guy of all time of all time
fans don't like this guy how you guys
used to be buddies though how do we get
to the point where you're fighting on
sunday
we weren't buddies okay okay he was more
my boss
um so i'm contracted to him not aew
and essentially for the past three years
i've been his bodyguard and i've been
the reason that he does not have his jaw
wired shot now i'm going to be be the
reason he does have his jaw wired shut
you know you you treat people
poorly
and you under appreciate them
you know eventually you gotta make the
choice to
quit or say sayonara to your boss and
take your own route in life and that's
what i've done and you are taking your
own route i mean you are i mean your
start already but you are like the next
big thing in pro wrestling what does
that feel like i mean you you know that
right you are the i mean you're already
a big thing but you are the it guy right
now in my mind at least yeah you know
it's weird hearing you say that it's
something i've believed since i was a
child that i was going to be um now i
hear people saying that i am
it's hard to truly comprehend
um it's very surreal but i'm very
blessed and happy to be where i'm at
the name wardlow where does it come from
my birth certificate is your last name
with a name like ward low i mean you're
destined to be a wrestling superstar you
yeah it's kind of already written out
and you're what six foot four stand up
let's see here stand up
okay how tall are you six three you're
six three look at this 265 and i'm uh
i'm i'm mjf's height so imagine sunday
night me and you going at it i think
you're bigger than mjs
here i come to aew on sunday you're look
at you your specimen what's your workout
routine oh man
it changes every so often
but we stick to you know heavy squats
deadlifts presses
a lot of nfl type training for
athleticism
but yeah i'm in the gym multiple times a
day most days now vegas you had uh that
was on wednesday night the show on
wednesday night the crowd went nuts for
you the big pay-per-view on sunday
there's a show tonight that sold out
what are you doing in your down time
besides being on las vegas now you're
going out hanging out partying stuff oh
no you're feeling oh i'm i'm more
focused than i've ever been in my whole
life um it truly doesn't even feel like
i'm in vegas because i i'm just the same
normal routine my daily routine now
after i demolish max sunday maybe we'll
go out and say oh what about in sailor
break you know my friend rocky she's
she's uh you saw rocky over there
she's yeah she's single okay she knows
the lay of the land okay i'm just saying
maybe she could show me around yes after
the victory party rocky can we plan it
victory party i mean yeah
okay thank you rocky all right listen
sunday night is going to be a blast i
mean you're one of the main matches we
also have hangman against cm pawn cootie
liking that match oh man i've wrestled
both individuals and both are
as tough as they come
um
i will say it is surreal to have cm punk
oh my gosh main event in our
pay-per-view for that for the time
anyway look at you taking out the
security at the here at the semicolon
arena on wednesday night boom here we go
oh yeah there goes another one you took
out ten guys with one hand
what are you doing here man you're mad
man i love it all right we gotta wrap it
up i appreciate it thank you so much for
joining us aew's double or nothing
pay-per-view is sunday at t-mobile arena
for more information go to all elite
wrestling dot-com
must-see
must-see biggest show of the year we'll
send it over to you rocky thanks jc he
does